إعلان ضخم أصدرته
اليوم وأريد التركيز عليه
لأنني أعتقد أنه
مهم للغاية
وهو يركز على ما تسميه وأعتقد
أنه طريقة رائعة لوضعه في
مجموعة مواهب ضخمة غير مستغلة في
العالم وهي  أولئك الذين هم معاقون بطريقة ما
وأنت تقوم بخطوات ضخمة
خاصة على مدى السنوات الخمس المقبلة لمحاولة
تضييق ما تسمونه تقسيم الإعاقة ،
تحدث معي من
خلال الإعلان اليوم متأكدًا من أنه
مهم حقًا وأعتقد أنه
فرصة للجميع  علينا أن
نفكر أكثر قليلاً في حقيقة
أن أكثر
من مليار شخص حول العالم في
مرحلة ما من حياتهم
إما بشكل مؤقت أو دائم
سيكونون مصابين بنوع من الإعاقة
، فقد يكون ذلك متعلقًا بالسمع أو البصر
أو أشياء أخرى
وعندما نكون  انظر إلى العالم اليوم ،
هناك موهبة هائلة في هذا
المجتمع ،
ولكن هناك 33 فقط من الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة
يعملون حاليًا مقارنة
بـ 76
من أقرانهم ، وهذا أمر هائل حقًا
divide ونرى أن التكنولوجيا الرقمية
يمكن أن تساعد في
سد هذه الفجوة يمكنها أن تمكّن الأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة من أن يكونوا أكثر
إنتاجية وخاصة إذا استطعنا البناء على ذلك
للمساعدة حقًا في جذب الأشخاص
إلى القوى العاملة لمنحهم هذه
المهارات الرقمية
التي ستساعدهم في الحصول عليها  وظيفة من شأنها أن
تساعد أرباب العمل
على تحديد هذه الموهبة بشكل أفضل ومن ثم
جعل مكان العمل
نفسه أكثر شمولاً للأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة
في وقت ننظر فيه في بعض البلدان
إلى نقص محتمل في العمالة ،
فهذه موهبة رائعة يمكن أن تساعد
الاقتصاد على الاستمرار في التحرك  إلى الأمام ،
كنت أنظر إلى بعض هذه
الإحصائيات حول هذا أيضًا ، أعني أنه
حتى في الولايات المتحدة وحدها ، يعيش واحد من كل
أربعة أشخاص يعانون من شكل من أشكال
الإعاقة في فقر ، والأسوأ إذا كنت
أقلية ، لذلك هناك العديد من الجوانب لهذا الأمر
إذا كنت تحاول التعامل مع أحدها فقط ،
اجعله قابلاً للتنفيذ بالنسبة لنا ، فقط كن محددًا
بشأن ما تفعله هنا لأن
بعضًا منه يتعلق بتوفير معلومات
إعادة العاملين بالمهارات الرقمية حتى
يتمكنوا من دعم أولئك
الذين يدعمونهم ومساعدتك في
الشراكة مع الجامعات أيضًا لأن
الأمر لا يتعلق فقط بمكان العمل ، بل
يتعلق بالتعليم قبل أن تصل إلى
هناك ، وحتى مع
حصولك على شهادة جامعية  لا يزال من غير المرجح أن يتم تعيينك ،
لذلك هناك العديد من الجوانب التي تعالجها هنا
في محاولة للمساعدة
في هذا الأمر
بشكل جيد ، وأعتقد أنك قلت ذلك جيدًا
وفي بعض النواحي لجلب الأشخاص إلى
القوى العاملة ، فإنه يبدأ
أه مع نظام التعليم الذي  لماذا
نعمل مع المزيد من الجامعات
لجعل الفصول الدراسية التي تبدأ من
رياض الأطفال وحتى التعليم العالي
أكثر سهولة ويسهل على الأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة التنقل فيها ،
ولكن بعد ذلك يعتمد الكثير منها أيضًا على
الأدوات الرقمية ،
تخيل أنك تحاول القيام بوظائفنا اليوم
بدون القدرة على
استخدام الكمبيوتر بشكل فعال لجميع
الأشياء التي نعتمد عليها ، فإننا نبني المزيد
والمزيد من التكنولوجيا في
أجهزتنا وخدماتنا للقيام بذلك
الأشياء التي ستسهل على
المجتمع المكفوف أو
ضعاف البصر بشكل عام
الاستفادة من
قارئات الشاشة الغامرة بالتكنولوجيا
وما شابه ذلك من التعليقات
التوضيحية لمجتمع الصم ، ولكن
عندما
تنظر إلى شيء مثل مقدمي الرعاية المنزلية ،
فإننا نريد تدريبهم  لذلك عندما
يكونون في منازل بها أشخاص
معاقون ،
فإنهم في وضع يسمح لهم بمساعدة هذا
المجتمع على
تعلم كيفية استخدام هذه الأدوات
ونريد توفير
المزيد من الأدوات لمطوري البرامج ، لذلك
عندما يقومون بإنشاء
برامجهم ، فإنهم في الواقع  القيام
بذلك مع
فلسفة إمكانية الوصول هذه عن طريق التصميم
في البداية ، لذلك نحن نركز عليها كما
نفعل دائمًا بالبدء بمنتجاتنا الخاصة ،
لكن هذه حركة ، إنها حركة
اكتسبت قوة جذب
لكنها حركة يمكن أن تنتشر كثيرًا
بسرعة أكبر على مدى السنوات الخمس
المقبلة ، وأعتقد أن القيام بذلك سوف
تغير حقًا التحول إذا كنت تريد
أنواع الفرص للأشخاص
ذوي الإعاقة